[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم معكم سهام قشطه لنستعرض معا
ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي بايجاز ضمن
ابرز الاحداث اشتباكات في مخيم عين الحلوه
اعمال عنف ضد مسلمي الهند انجاز تاريخي
لسيدات المغرب
لنبدا مع تطورات المتسارعه في النيجر
ابرزها تحذير المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول
غرب افريقيا بالتدخل العسكري اذا لم يبادر
الانقلابيون باعاده الرئيس بازوم الى
السلطه وفي المواقف الدوليه قالت روسيا ان
اي تدخل خارجي لن يسهم في حل الازمه بينما
اعلنت الولايات المتحده وقفا مؤقتا لبعض
برامج المساعده من ناحيه اخرى الغى ما
يطلق على نفسه المجلس الوطني لحمايه الوطن
اتفاقيات تعاون عسكري مع فرنسا عن التلويح
بتدخل العسكري من دول الاكواس ساسال زميلي
بابا ولد حرمه المتخصص في الشان الافريقيه
بابا برايك ما مدى جديه هذا التحذير تبدو
بالفعلتها تقترب من النهايه المهله التي
اعطتها لنقلب بنا في النيجر طبعا لدوليه
تجربه طويله تمتد 19 حتى الان في تداخليه
العسكريه في الدولي الاعضاء في هذه
المنظمه
الابرز خاصه
وتدخلها في السيراليون نهايه التسعينيات
اذ نجحت في عده رئيس المنتخب حينها
والمنقلب عليه باحمد تيزان كبه الى سده
الحكم كما كذلك لها تجربه مشابهه من خلال
الضغط ونشر القوات العسكريه ان ترغم
الرئيس يحيى جميعا على مغادره سدتي الحكم
شكرا لك بابا ولد الحرمه
مخيم عين الحلوه للاجئين الفلسطينيين في
لبنان كان محور التوتر المتصاعد خلال
الاسبوع الماضي اثر الشبكات بعد مقتل عده
اشخاص بينهم قائد قوات الامن الوطني
الفلسطيني في صيدا فصائل فلسطينيه اعلنت
التوصل لهدنه الا ان وقف اطلاق النار لم
يصمد اكثر من 24 ساعه واصطى حركه نزوح
كبيره للاهالي وتخوف من عمليات تهجير
للسكان في حين وصف رئيس الحكومه اللبنانيه
نجيب ميقاتي الاقتتال بالانتهاك الصارخ
لسياده لبنان لكن ماذا في تفاصيل هذا
الغليان لنسال مراسلنا ايهاب العقدي الذي
يغطي هذه الاحداث
كيف تبدو الاوضاع في المخيم ايهاب نعم
سهام ما عاد الهدوء الى مخيم عين الحلوه
للاجئين الفلسطينيين في لبنان اكبر
المخيمات الفلسطينيه وذلك بعد اشتباكات
استمرت عده ايام بين حركات فتح ومجموعات
تطلق على نفسها اسم اسلاميه
ادى الامر الى مقتل اثني عشر شخصا وجرحي
نحو ستين بالاضافه الى الحاق اضرار كبيره
بمنازل الفلسطينيين داخل المخيم
وبمتلكاتهم وبالبنيه التحتيه
شكرا ايهاب الى الهند التي شهدت على مدار
الاسبوع الماضي اعمال عنف وانتهاكات ضد
المسلمين في ولايه هاريانا حيث قامت
مجموعه هندوسيه باستهداف المساجد في
المدينه وقتل احد ائمتها واحراقها
والاعتداء على المحل التجاريه وممتلكات
المسلمين مطوره العديد من العائلات
المسلمه لمغادره الولايه وترك بيوتهم خوفا
من ان تطالهم هذه الاعتداءات تصاعد اعمال
للعنف ضد المسلمين في الهند قبل بموجه غضب
عربي واسلامي على المنصات لنلقي نظره على
ابرز تفاعلاتكم حيث وعلق الامام الخطيب
السعوديه عماد المبيض قائلا المسلمون في
الهند لاب وكيلهم متطرفون هندوس يحرقون
مسجدا ويقتلون امامه في ولايتها ريان
الهنديه اي دور لمنظمه العالم الاسلامي
التي من اهدافها الدفاع عن الاسلام
والمسلمين بينما قال المستشار الاعلاميه
يعرب الحسون
كافه الدول العربيه والاسلاميه اتخاذ
الاجراءات الضروريه ضد حكومه الهندوس
ووضعوا حد لهذه المجازر الفظيعه في الهند
بحق المسلمين الى تركيا التي تعيش على وقع
حمله امنيه تستهدف المهاجرين غير
النظاميين اذ سجل كثير من حالات الترحيل
التي شملت مئات الاجانب من جنسيات مختلفه
في مقدمتهم الافغان والسوريون حقوقيون
قالوا ان هناك اخطاء شابت بعد اجراءاته
وخاصه انه يتزامن مع جدل واسع بشان تزايد
الخطاب العنصري وتنامي ظاهره العداء
للاجئين اذا اردتم معرفه المزيد عن هذه
الحمله الامنيه في التعليقات تجدون فيديو
يشرح لكم تداعياتها والجدل الكبير الذي
اثارته في تركيا
اسعار الارز ترتفع لاعلى مستوى لها منذ
سنوات وسط تحذيرات من ازمه عالميه محلات
البقاله في دول مختلفه شهدت تهافتا على
شرائه مضطر بعضها الى بيع عبوه واحده
للفرد كحد اقصى كل هذا يحدث بعد قرار
الهند حضر تصدير بعض انواع الارز لخفض
الاسعار المحليه اذ تعد الهند اكبر مصدره
للارز في العالم وتساهم بحوالي 40% من
التجاره العالميه في الحكومه المنتخب
المغربي يحقق انجازا تاريخيا في منافسات
كاس العالم للسيدات التي يشارك فيها للمره
الاولى حيث حقق انتصارين على كولومبيا
وكوريا الجنوبيه في المجموعه الثامنه
مكانه من التاهل الى دور 16 وسيلعب
المنتخب المغربي بذلك مع فرنسا متصدره
المجموعه السادسه في البطوله المقامه في
استراليا ونيوزيلندا اذا انجاز عربي جديد
حققته سيدات المغرب عن ذلك اسال زميلنا
مجيد بطنبيين مجيد حظوظ المنتخب المغربي
في التاهل لدور الربع وهل كانت هذه
النتيجه متوقعه شكرا سهام في الحقيقه
النتيجه لم تكن متوقعه خاصه بعد البدايه
المتعثره لصله المغرب سته صفر امام
المانيا ولكن تمكنا من العوده بقوه امام
كوريا الجنوبيه الفوز واحد صفر وبنفس
النتيجه امام كولومبيا منتخب كولومبيا كان
قوي جدا واستحقنا التاهل في اول مشاركه
لهن الى الدور الثاني الان المهمه امام
سيدات فرنسا تبدو في غايه الصعوبه ولكن كل
شيء ممكن للسيدات المغرب اللائي يسرنا على
خطى اسود الاطلس في موديل قطر 2022
بالتوفيق للسيدات المغرب شكرا لك مسجد كان
هذا ايجازنا لهذا الاسبوع نلتقي في
الاسبوع المقبل
[موسيقى]